SDN has many advantages over conventional networks. It's
easier to coordinate behavior among a network of devices.
The behavior of the network is easier to evolve,
and it's also easier to reason about. These characteristics
are all rooted in the fact that the
control plan is separate from the data plan. Having
a separate control plane or control program allows us
to provide conventional cs techniques to old networking problems.
So as before it was incredibly difficult
to reason about or debug a network's behavior
if the network behavior is now controlled
by a logically centralized control program. We can
use techniques from programming languages or software
engineering to help us reason about the behavior
of the network. As far as SDN's
infrastructure is concerned, the Control Plane is typically
a software program written in a high level language, such as Python or C,
on the other hand the Data Plane.
Is typically programmable hardware that's controlled by
the control plane. The controller effects the
forwarding state that's in the switch using
control commands. Open flow is one standard
that defines a set of control commands by
which the controller can control the behavior of one or more switches.
SDN has many applications including data centers, wide area
backbone networks, enterprise networks, internet exchange
points or IXPs, and home networks. Later
modules in this course will explore how software defined networks. Can solve
network management problems in some of these areas. In this
course we will focus in particular on the first three applications.